i know you're a film buff and uh and
we've established that you live in a
theater now
uh your daughter alice this seems to me
because this is what i've been doing
with my kids
i've been trying to use this time to say
hey we're all here together
you're gonna watch yeah great great
movies with me
and they do and they really like them
what have you been showing your daughter
uh what what kind of stuff have you been
showing her it's been amazing i've been
showing her a lot of the movies that i
grew up on so i showed i've shown her
groundhog day she loved it i showed her
raising arizona which is a surprisingly
good kids movie for like kids 11 and up
there's not really that much cursing and
all the violence is like a
it's like a roadrunner cartoon it's a
it's very cartoony it's a great movie
yeah but then i also showed her the
first matrix film
which um she thought was hilarious and
like
so they go into a computer and they can
do anything and
things just like when i would go see
star wars when i was little and then i
immediately wanted to
fight with the light like i got a broom
handle and fought like a lightsaber
she wanted to do the matrix so she
we have a trampoline in the backyard and
she made me
film her in matrix style which i also
have some film of if you want to show
that
yeah yeah we have this and
it's pretty cool because uh she does a
pretty good move in slow motion
yeah she kind of lands a move so if you
want to yeah check that out let's put
that up right now
take a look
that is quite impressive and it makes
you wonder why more of the matrix didn't
take place on a child's trampoline
on a child's exactly why didn't they use
that more and why didn't they have the
thing where
i mean she basically figured out a way
to do
frozen bullet time yeah raises her
bullet in the net
in the net yeah they're spending way too
much money on those films they don't
need
you just need a net and a trampoline
tell me tell me how the movie looks any
better than that movie that i just shot
i mean seriously i have a good
recommendation for people out there for
you too i watched this
uh the other day i had a craving for
kind of a cheesy movie i wanted to kind
of hate watch something
so uh death wish three death wish three
i'm telling you uh yes uh charles
bronson
arrives in new york city he arrives and
it was shot in 1985
he arrives in a perfectly fine new york
city he shows up at the port authority
everything's functioning fine he gets in
a cab and he goes to a part of the bronx
where there are dirt roads yes dirt
roads
no law gangs riding around
everything's on fire no one's calling
the cops are like what are you gonna do
we've lost control and i'm like call in
the army for god's sake
it's insanity edgar wright is obsessed
with that movie
he i he he and i talk about the movie
all the time
one yes it was shot in 88 it was shot in
london there's an the establishment
coming to the port authority
they shot that and the rest of it they
went over to london they
barely disguise london as new york
that's why it looks like this it doesn't
we it doesn't look like america at all
um he's flat out murdering people in the
street when he shoots the giggler
and there's every there's like 20
witnesses
watch this guy bait the dude shoot him
in the back and i'll go
yeah they're all just hearing a murderer
it is an insane movie
and uh i'm i i think if anyone takes
anything away from this
work listen today we're we're not just
mentioning your projects
uh i love uh everything and i'll be gone
in the dark
we are also plugging deathwish three
and you know what they shot the giggler
man
[Laughter]
oh and the big villain in the movie with
the reverse
mohawk remember because what at the time
they're like
well we already got the punks with the
mohawks and i think people are used to
that
so how do we freak we'll do a reverse
mohawk
the actor who plays that guy played
chuck on happy days that was
richie cunningham's older brother older
brother who never appeared again
in the show who apparently vanished went
to the bronx and became an insane
mutant criminal uh you know it's the
weird thing about happy days and i know
this is you and i we can go down these
rabbit holes
and not get to anything we're supposed
to talk about but the crazy thing about
happy days is i think it's
it's the it's one of the sitcoms one of
the only ones i can think of
where they introduce a family in the
first season
and there's an older brother now the
easy thing to do in the second season is
say
yeah he went away you know he's in the
army he's traveling
he's no suddenly they're off they're a
family
that never had an older brother and it's
scary it's
scary yeah it was in i wonder how many
people that scarred like were their kids
like
if i misbehave can my family just kind
of vanish me or
disappear me yeah like in in the
pictures like they stalling that dude
out of that
he's just airbrushed out of everything
you